bonjour merci d'être avec nous alors
quelle est la stratégie politique de
sebastian pinera avec ce remaniement
bonjour ce qu'on voit avec cette le
remaniement c'est vraiment un virage
vers la droite plus conservatrices la
droite plus dures et les présidents
sébastien piña ne s'en cache plus de
vouloir préserver un modèle néolibéral
est hérité de la dictature de pinochet
et les stratégies qui prépare maintenant
c'est pouvoir exercer une certaine
pouvoir pour que les gens aillent voter
pour ne pas changer la constitution de
pinochet qui étions a hérité de la
dictature
donc ce qu'on voit bien maintenant c'est
qu'il n'y a plus de dialogue social il
ya plus d dialogue avec les partenaires
sociaux
et il a dit clairement qu'il n'avait pas
changé les systèmes justement on en a
qu'on attente en quoi de ce référendum
constitutionnel qui doit avoir lieu le
25 octobre
bon d'abord ce que les gens veulent
c'est que ces référents et puis savoir
dire parce que il était prévu pour avril
décalé à cause de coronavirus et et les
gens ils ne sont pas sûrs qu'ils
pourront aller voter en octobre parce
que le chili il est encore confiné à
cause de duke au vide mais ce qu'ils
attendent c'est pouvoir changer et ré
écrire une constitution d'une façon plus
démocratique puisque la constitution
d'aujourd'hui il ne leur permet pas
pouvoir toucher des aspects si
importants comme l'éducation la santé ou
même les retraites justement pour sur
les retraites on a donc autorisé les
chiliens a puisé 10% de leurs fondent
retraite pour faire face à la pendaison
à la pandémie du coronavirus on peut
parler d'une décision historique
oui c'est exactement c'est une décision
historique
c'était l'alliance entre une partie de
la droite avec la gauche
mais surtout ce qui montre cette
alliance c'est un schisme au milieu du
gouvernement parce que on voit
confronter deux droites une droite
technocrates idéologique contre une
droite du terrain qui est qui doit
rendre compte à ses administrés donc ce
qu'on voit c'est vraiment une séparation
très nette entre deux de droite qui ne
s'entend plus rocher et quelle est la
situation au chili après plusieurs mois
de crise sociale et de crise sanitaire
bon les chili il a déjà commencé avec la
crise sociale en octobre 2019 est ce
qu'on voit c'est qu'ils en rajoutent une
crise sanitaire et on va rajouter aussi
une crise économique
les études montrent que bon dans toute
l'amérique latine
eva il va y avoir une augmentation de la
pauvreté et au chili
il estime que la pauvreté n'est pas
celle d'un 9 1 13% ce qui pouvait être
pourrait éventuellement provoquer encore
une fois une nouvelle explosion sociale
de peut-être un peu plus fort un peu
plus violente puisque les des mondes qui
sont été fait avant l'année dernière
n'ont pas été résolus et asselah on va
rajouter encore une certaine rage des
tous ces gens qui sont morts qui sont
pas pu être soignées et en plus un
chômage qui explose et il prend pauvreté
qui augmente et d écart qui se creuse
entre les plus riches et les plus
pauvres gars prêts là bravo merci
d'avoir être avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste chilienne
correspondante à paris merci